hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are in the finals and it's Game three
Game one ended by Magnus winning the
game then he caught retaliated in Game
two and now again Magnus would the white
pieces it's Game three let's see let's
see what happened so Magnus opens with
d4 yeah we have nine 256 c4 e6 knight of
3 and d5 again we have the Queens gambit
declined and Knight to c3 will push up
the e7 and again Carlson goes for his
Bishop to f4 line we have castles and
III now just preparing to develop the
LightSquared Bishop Knight bt7 and now
Bishop to e2 we have d captures on c4
and now Magnus just castles we have c5
immediately striking in the center and
here we have a couple of trades we have
captures Bishop captures and Bishop
captures and c4 followed by a6 preparing
b5 so
Knight to g5 by Magnus and now just be 5
by Nakamura forcing the bishop to move
but here you don't just move the bishop
rather as the title suggests you
sacrifice it on e6 and it's not a new
move it's been seen before Rafa Tasha
plated against the Dmitri and raking in
the 2019 Jerusalem Grand Prix
so Bishop captures only six captures and
now Knight captures on e6 so grabbing
grabbing two points and also you will
win the rook for for your two pieces so
Quinta yet is the move that was played
by and raking against wait a sec that
game ended in a draw in 2019 but here we
have Queen to e7 by Nakamura and it is
as a move 13 that we have a completely
new game it doesn't really change all
that much with Knight captures on f8 and
the Queen captures back on f8 we have
Knight to e4 now also most likely a
prepared idea now the point is if you
capture the night Quinta d5 check just
picks up the rookin a it so of course
Nakamura doesn't go for that you have to
develop it there should be seven puts
pressure on the night and here just
tonight captures on c5 by Magnus we have
Queen captures on c5 bringing the Queen
into the game but now rook the c1 the
row comes into the game with tempo Queen
d5 offering a queen trade but also
threatening
checkmate on Jeju so Magnus defense'll
would have three and here you could go
for the immediate Queen trade however
white will be very happy playing the
same game and it's not easy for for
black to continue playing even though he
has two nights for a rook it's not not
not very easy if your uki 84 will be
very strong if you go look to see it you
can just trade and go rook to c1 for
example the Shabak you're gonna go rook
here pressure the best shot after the
bishop moves b3 let's say and then you
go after the pawn for example it will be
very hard for black to play this so
instead nakamura first grabs the pawn he
can always straight Queens later and we
have efore by Magnus now offering the b2
pawn now but not really offering it
because if you capture it and rook the
c7 is very strong if there's just the
threat of capturing the knight here
picking up to the backyard material and
if you defended let's say better state
than e5 is becomes extremely strong you
will again lose material because the
knight cannot move Queen d5 check will
again pick up the rook once the bishop
moves so a pretty tricky idea if for if
I will always be an idea if the bishop
moves from this diagonal so Knight the
f8 by Hikaru and now look to F to Magnus
defends the pawn but also you can just
easily double up here if needed so rook
the c8 by Hikaru and here Magnus trades
one of the rooks with Bishop characteris
Bishop rook captures Bishop characters
and then now Queen to d8 put in fresh
run the bishop here also preparing
Bishop d6 just easily checkmate the
black king so Quinta e6 defending the
bishop and Magnus continues with Bishop
to d6 putting pressure on f8 and he
corona goes Quinta eh offering a queen
trade and stopping mate
Magnus trades we have Queen captures and
Knight captures and Bashar back to
before and we entered this endgame where
Carson is up only one pawn and he has a
rook for two nights which is usually not
enough usually two pieces will be will
be better than the rook but here it's
it's it's a question of how you will
mobilize those pieces so he car starts
with Knight to e6 Magnus goes roof to d2
you have to put the rook on an open file
and King to f7 key car starts improving
the position of the king Magnus does
same amount Knight to f6 we have King to
e3 and g5 by Hikaru grabbing more space
on the kingside and rook to d6 now
putting pressure on a lot of pieces here
controlling the sixth rank not allowing
the bishop to move we have to keep an
eye on the a6 pawn and now Knight to d7
we have g3 by Magnus and now Knight to
e5 and here just b3 taking away the c-4
square from he car is nice
so the Bishop and pawn really do a good
job not allowing those Knights to land
anywhere and also you can't really go
anywhere on the Kings side so h5 by
Hikaru and now just h4 by Magnus which
does this trade off upon and messes up
he correspond structure here however you
also give the Knights I'm jumping ideas
so captures captures in Knight to g6 now
goes after the h4 pawn but it's not a
problem Magnus just goes to the bishop
back to e 1 now it defends the pawn here
and now by doing this you kind of do
give up on the c5 square however if you
do this then work the c6 just wins the
material so you're not really giving the
knife the c5 square so here instead he
Carl tried a 5 he wants to play a 4 and
create a passed pawn on the Queen side
and also he's suggesting a trade I give
you the a 5 point of 44 th for pawn and
which also creates me the past H pawn
however Magnus doesn't doesn't go for it
instead he goes for the absolute
strongest move which you're even welcome
to pause the video and try and spot
since it's a very nice position well I
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding rook to b5
as it is the strongest move and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
it's still rook to d5 now you're going
after this pawn you're going after this
pawn and Magnus is not afraid of a4
which is exactly what he carved plays
and now he just grabs the h5 pawn we
have Knight eat f4 by Hikaru now
threatening well not only the rook but
after the rook moves you can go nice to
G to check there will be the threat of
picking up the bishop also you will pick
up the h4 pawn if the bishop is defended
but Magnus just goes rook to g5 he
doesn't allow Knight G to check and he
shows that well ideas like a three or a
capture some b3 are not a problem since
you always have this bishop the c3 move
so he Carl grabs the b3 pawn but now
just h5 by Magnus Hikaru finds the
tricky knife to f8 saying okay you're
welcome to grab by night however if you
grab it you get 96 check and after the
King moves I'm gonna grab your look and
now this is an issue and even if you
defend it I'm still better now in the
endgame as I'm up a piece so instead
after night to a fate Magnus went for
blush of the c3 guarding b2 but also
having the eight sheet Square covered
which is the queening square so if the H
pawn starts marching up the board could
be very problematic here Hikaru goes b4
hopes for characters and then B to
Magnus of course goes Buster back to be
2 and now Knight 8 the e6 attacking the
rook and guarding the the night here
but here Magnus just goes for rook to f5
with check with King to g8 of course
keeping an eye on the h7 square but now
Magnus goes for the absolutely easiest
way of converting this endgame which of
course you see without even pausing the
video and that is rook captures on f4 or
you give up the rook for two nights and
now you play the same game bishops of
opposite colors however if you if you
know your end games you know you will
win this so Knight captures King
captures and now Bishop the a6 he Karl
will of course try to hold the setup
some sort of a barrier along the light
squares but King g5 with Bishop to d3
now if you push you lose
upon but to just pink the g6 now the
thread is h6 h7 check and since the
point of a bishop covers h8 h8 will be
game over so but should the b5 first and
now if if h6 you can go Bishop e8 check
will force the King back and then you
will no longer have access to the h7
square so f4 instead not worrying about
this with bishop th check thinking back
to g5 with Bishop to c6 going after the
pawn here but now just be 5 with Bishop
to d5 not allowing the bishop to the
pond to reach the square but now f5 so
now to connected fast bones are
incredibly strong we have king to h7 but
now e 6 just continuing to push that
pawn with Bishop to c4 and now came to
f6 and Nakamura goes Bishop to e2 he
goes after the h5 pawn but Magnus
ignores that he just goes for king to e7
and he was in his position on more 52
that Hikaru Nakamura resigned the game
and Magnus again takes the lead and
Hikaru is now in a must-win situation in
in game four of their match he needs to
win with the white pieces to force the
mini blitz blitz mini matches so now
here we resign because there is nothing
for you to do this point will Queen
whatever you do whether you capture the
pawn or not just f6 f7 and f8 will be
will be Queen
very nice game and even though what a
shock only got a draw against Andre
Keane with that Bishop captures and e6
idea Magnus perfected it and was able to
grab a full point from from Hikaru
so quite the line so now once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Niels wild Carl Nielsen Blair
Barnes Bryce Foster and Donald Kinsey
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon most likely with Game
four of the match he car Nakamura vs.
Magnus Carlsen from the finals of the
Magnus invitational I think though I
will see soon and have an excellent rest
of your Sunday